bonsoir claude blanchemaison merci
d'être avec nous alors pourquoi la
relation entre elles la france et
l'egypte est elle aussi importante c'est
pas nouveau c'est une vieille affaire
sans remonter au xviiie siècle et à
l'expédition d'egypte de bonaparte qui
avait emmené comme vous le savez 160
savant français dont celui qui allait
découvrir plus tard la façon de
décrypter les hiéroglyphes dans le fond
si les égyptiens savent lire aujourd'hui
les hiéroglyphes de l'egypte ancienne
c'est grâce à un savant français
plus récemment l'egypte avait décidé de
rentrer dans de devenir membre de la
l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie
alors qu il y a peu de francophones
aujourd'hui en egypte c'était un choix
politique est d'ailleurs boutros ghali
ancien secrétaire-général de l'onu est
devenue le secrétaire-général de
l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie
alors là des choses se sont un peu
accéléré en effet depuis l'arrivée au
pouvoir de monsieur de du président ici
puisque depuis 2014
on peut estimer que chaque année où tous
les 18 mois au maximum
il ya une visite d'état dans un sens ou
dans l'autre monsieur sisi est venu en
visite d'état en france
dès son élection en 2014 monsieur
hollande est allé l'année suivante en
egypte il a aussi assisté au doublement
de la capacité du canal de suez
et puis en 2017 eh bien il ya eu une
nouvelle visite de monsieur sisi en
france 2019
monsieur macouin fait du sud et à la
visite d'aujourd'hui c'est la vitre tour
c'est dans la pratique diplomatique
normale
alors évidemment il ya beaucoup de
points de convergence en matière
politique
le premier le plus important c'est
certainement la lutte contre le
terrorisme puisque les analyses
française et égyptienne sont totalement
convergente
c'est aussi la sphère de la libye où là
la france comme l'egypte considère qu'
il faut absolument appliquer le cessez
le feu
il faut mener à bien le dialogue
politique et qu'il faut éviter les
interventions extérieures
et puis la crise en méditerranée
orientale
évidemment là c'est encore la turquie
qui est visé
puisque les deux pays considère qu' il
ne faut pas qu'ils interventions
intempestives qui viennent bousculer les
zones économiques exclusives et les
possibilités de recherche
d'hydrocarbures dans la région donc cela
fait beaucoup de points communs plus les
accords de coopération beaucoup
d'entreprises françaises sont installées
en egypte et par conséquent il ya
beaucoup de sujets de coopération dans
divers domaines et je crois que demain
le président si six rencontres
le président du sénat qui la rencontre
est ce soir le président de l'assemblée
nationale et la maire de paris ça fait
partie du protocole d'une visite d'état
la mère du paris lui a sans doute
également beaucoup parlé en effet les
droits de l'homme alors cette visite
justement du président égyptien est
vraiment critiquée en france
oui elle est critiquée par un certain
nombre de partis politiques par les ong
par un certain nombre de militants des
droits de l'homme parce que en effet il
semble qu'il y ait envie de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de prisonniers
politiques en egypte et les deux
présidents sont d'ailleurs expliqué
devant les journalistes dans leur point
de presse commun et le président 6,6
répond oui mais naturellement notre
région est particulièrement dangereuse
et moi je veux lutter contre tous les
terroristes islamistes y compris
d'ailleurs contre les frères musulmans
or en egypte qui l'a remplacé monsieur
morsi qui appartenait à la confrérie des
frères musulmans et les frères musulmans
sont souvent soupçonné d'une certaine
complaisance il à vis de terroristes
islamistes
évidemment cela n'est pas une raison
pour mettre en prison des journalistes
des avocats des gens qui appartiennent à
la société civile et on a en effet cette
situation qui fait que les ong
01/10 pourquoi ventes ont de l'armement
désarmement des équipements militaires à
un pays qui n'appliquent pas les droits
de l'homme alors justement l'armement
occar un de ses relations entre les deux
pays quelles perspectives pour la france
pour ce marché concurrentiel de
l'armement alors en 2014 eux c'étaient
les etats-unis qui étaient le premier
fournisseur de l'egypte et puis les
difficultés au congrès donc le
ralentissement des fournitures
américaine et finalement aujourd'hui
c'est la france qui est le premier
fournisseur d'armements à l'egypte la
russie et le second et les etats unis
sont le troisième mais il ya évidemment
d'autres pays qui vendent aussi les
armements la grande bretagne l'allemagne
et beaucoup d'autres pays parce que
c'est un pays qui en effet vivant dans
une région particulièrement dangereuse a
besoin de s'équiper
surtout que naturellement l'egypte n'a
jamais cherché à bénéficier de l'armé
nucléaire et qu'il ya d'autres pays dans
la région qui l'on pourrait bien avoir
donc y est évidemment pour l'egypte
c'est un enjeu tout à fait essentiel
c'est un marché très compétitif et je
crois qu'à l'avenir le président 6,6
aura le seul eu le souhait de conserver
cette diversification des
approvisionnements naturellement et
surtout qu'il cherchera à apprécier la
fiabilité des différents fournisseurs et
évidemment également les risques de
sanctions
merci à tous de blanche maison expert en
relations internationales